basic science represents
curiosity we decided to break it up into
distinct disciplines like biology
chemistry and astronomy but ultimately
it's all the same kind of curiosity
which is how did things work how did
they begin how do they end that is
essential to the nature of what it means
to be human science is about thinking
and new ways of seeing things maybe
there are things that we've actually
described in the same way for a thousand
years and then all of a sudden we find
some Discovery or some realization that
says we got to completely rethink the
way that we actually considered
this science does that more succinctly
than almost any other kind of human
endeavor and so every bit as much as we
appreciate art or poetry we appreciate
science
Yale it's an absolutely fabulous place
for scholarship its history is based on
learning and Discovery that's why we're
here Yale is an intellectual Hub it is a
place that has a strong Legacy of
originating some of the most exciting
new ideas our mission is to create new
knowledge and to transmit that knowledge
through our teaching the thrill of of
saying I have this question about how
the world Works Nobody Knows the answer
I'm going to go out and I'm going to
design the experiment or collect the
data or develop the theory that answers
that question and that pushes the
boundaries of human knowledge there's
nothing like it much of science is
laborious it's called a laboratory for a
reason and it's also very timec
consuming it takes a while before we can
actually see the importance of these
things that we do and and in fact what
really is happening is that we're doing
the slow process of thinking things
through science is unpredictable and I'd
like to think that institutions such as
ours offer the space for the more
creative unpredictable kind of work
where we don't know what the outcome's
going to be you want to be fearless and
not constrained by current thinking if
we're curious but we're not actually
ambitious and we're not brave enough to
sort of step outside of our comfort zone
then in fact we probably won't succeed
in making real
progress the big leaps forward the big
discoveries they often start by someone
who had a very specific question about a
very specific system or process and in
the course of answering that opened up
this whole new Vista for us these
projects are very granular but that is
how the frontiers of knowledge
expand when you're the first one to
actually see something and you know that
you're the first human being to know
that this is how it works that's an
incomparable experience it's exciting
it's really incredible to have the
opportunity to do what I do but it also
tends to have years down the road these
unexpected payoffs in which people had
no idea that this simple Discovery was
going to actually be applied in an area
that's very very different than what
they had assumed without the
foundational work that comes out of
basic Sciences there is no Light Signs
there is no
technology curiosity driven research at
Yale and Beyond has underpinned almost
every technological advance that you can
think of from food production to Heating
and Cooling to GPS to diagnostic medical
imaging we're talking about scientific
research what we're actually talking
about is an investment into the future
it's an almost guaranteed thing people
understand that the stock market goes up
and down but generally over time time
your investment is going to pay off and
that is certainly the case with science
a basic scientist tries to understand
the world we live in we seek the truth
we seek knowledge because there's just
so much out there to know right now in
Yale's faculty of Arts and Sciences
fundamental research is being done that
will end up Transforming Our
understanding of human health and
disease of Neuroscience of the quantum
world and
[Music]
Beyond